what do you think is specifically for
Chicago
um
the key to Breaking the cycle and I know
that it's hard to talk about yeah I mean
it because I think that I think it
starts with like guys like yourself who
are leaders
um and I think you do a really good job
of
of not uh participating in stuff that I
see some of your other kind of Parts
participating in
um but I know that it's really it's
really hard
um
to
once once people die once relatives die
or whatever I just I just I don't know
what is like you know I think for me at
least from an outsider look in it I
think it starts with you know like you
said like if you're in a position to
give back if you're in a position to be
a positive influence on on on the
generation below you I think that's a
lot you know and and I do want to give
you props because
I feel like I never see
um you wrapped up in negative [ __ ]
outside of you know hey you know maybe
you got to charge you're going straight
with your with your baby mama whatever
just dumb [ __ ] that you know you're a
famous person you're gonna deal with it
you're gonna deal with famous person
[ __ ] but I feel like
um you know I always say that like just
as an artist you've grown the most over
the years as a rapper you've you've
you've Leaps and Bounds lyrically but
all that should aside like I feel like
as a man like you're one of those
shining examples of like you know um
growth yeah like we saw you grow up in
front of our eyes and you know I want to
just give you kudos for not
participating in the [ __ ] [ __ ] that I
see a lot of people who you know are
your peers participating in but like
what do you think is the key to kind of
like
you're never going to stop everything
yeah for sure absolutely
um I think the key to it is opportunity
bro yeah people are opportunists so at
the end of the day if you're opportunist
and I'm not I may give you opportunity
because as an opportunist you may think
all right the way to feed my family is
to do this on the Internet or do this or
yeah because [ __ ] [ __ ] if you don't get
into the [ __ ] [ __ ] you see you see your
metrics the [ __ ] [ __ ] is what's feeding
people family but at the end of the day
it's what's in the families as well 100
that [ __ ] is feeding families and and
their families at the same time and it's
the short nut it's like yeah short you
feel and I I feel like for what I don't
wanna because I could I could feed into
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I could be on [ __ ]
[ __ ]
but I'm not for what I feel like I got
so much to lose and that's just from
experiencing life on so many ways bro
because I used to wake up every day on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but I ain't on that bro I wake up every
day in a big ass crib right with my kids
I don't even want to think about no [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying and it's
like at the end of the day it's so easy
to like snap back and like entertain
goofy [ __ ] or whatever but I feel like
the key component to internet is
opportunity bro you got to get a nigga's
opportunity and you gotta understand you
gotta be understanding of why [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] it's certain [ __ ] on
[ __ ] [ __ ] that don't have nothing else
to resort to but that they don't have no
other opportunities no ways of making
money they in they Hood all day where
it's nothing but negativity I could tell
you every day it was nothing but
negativity in my neighborhood every day
is some function going on it's the only
thing we still finding ways to smile
yeah to have fun my friends my best
friends dad I'm coming back on this
block every day and I'm still able to
crack a smile which is crazy that's
insane that's insane yeah if I'm saying
so to understand that is one of the main
reasons why I don't feed into it because
I understand I get why [ __ ] frustrated
I could get why a [ __ ] may be
frustrated even at me because I'm able
to live on this side of the fence that's
survivor's remorse and that's why I
understand like damn it's cool I know
you're going through this I really want
to help you
but I gotta be able to help you but you
gotta want to help yourself you gotta
want to help yourself but it's like
[ __ ] certain [ __ ] can't even help
they self because they in this
environment it's hard to want to help
yourself be when you enter you're just
trying to survive every time that's the
Survivor side I survived this [ __ ] so I
understand it different you know what
I'm saying like everything just tied
back into each other and it's like that
[ __ ] tough bro and I understand it
because I once come from that if I'm
saying so the reason why I don't feed
into it is because it ain't even worth
it to me well that takes a lot of
humility on your behalf to be like you
know what I'm not feeding into this [ __ ]
because I get it I was there I get it
yeah I get it if I'm saying like I was
once you I relate to you so I feel like
with me being an open book and being
vulnerable about this [ __ ] a [ __ ] would
be like damn he really do get it right
[ __ ] it let me just change everything
because I made the biggest sacrifice I
wouldn't be here today if I ain't say
[ __ ] everything bro and every [ __ ]
around me could contest to it I said
[ __ ] everything [ __ ] being on the Block
[ __ ] hanging with my friends [ __ ] rap I
said [ __ ] everything let me just get my
mind right bro I stay in my mama house
literally [ __ ] I had a condo downtown
when I was 17 years old bro I stayed in
my mama house in my 20s and just stayed
in the basement and just trying to like
think about life Bro think about where I
would be if I made certain decisions if
I'm saying if I was still outside
hanging on my block because I love my
hood so much but I got millions of
dollars if I'm saying I'm making
millions of dollars you know and that
was one of the toughest times I ever
been through in my life yeah people who
experience that with me know I went
through some tough [ __ ] and I overcame
that so I'm saying all I have to say is
no matter what you're going through in
your life or whatever tough times you're
going through you could just buckle down
embrace it and overcome it you know I'm
saying there's people going through
tougher [ __ ] than me of course so you
just gotta take it for what it is bro
and just try to be the best version of
yourself that you could be tomorrow than
you was yesterday and you keep trying to
do that and then you look up [ __ ] two
months then going back you're like damn
I think totally different right I can
get back out here and just do my thing
you feel me